i just been spending a lot of time with
family working on myself with them
and uh just staying resilient you know
uh keeping the mind
on the mission uh that's
being a football player and doing all
the things that come with that even when
the times got hard you know keeping
myself in shape keeping myself motivated
from within
uh not listening to the naysayers or not
giving doubt or worries about will i be
able to return you know i had good
trainers good people around me in my
corner that uh kept me encouraged uh
that kept me motivated
and i just uh believed you know uh
i knew one day i would get a chance to
be back in this position
and i just try to check every box to
make sure when i was able to get back
you know i was ready to go
that's antonio brown stringing together
into a quilt every possible cliche he
could utter with no real insight into
anything i don't want to be overly
critical of the guy but really it's one
cliche after another it's like tom brady
gave him a list of all the phrases to
use and the one thing that caught my
attention don't listen to the naysayers
look antonio the naysayers aren't being
unfair to you the naysayers are pointing
out the things that you have done right
the behavior in which you have engaged
that has caused you to not play football
for the last two seasons it's your fault
not ours and and you have deprived
yourself of an opportunity to
to perform in the waning years of your
prime if you're still in your prime and
you know that's not on us that's on you
antonio brown so don't i know they find
motivation anywhere they can but don't
call out the naysayers when we're merely
pointing out the train wreck that he's
been the engineer of chris yeah no i
mean i agreed with that i mean it's a
little bit of a theme in you know just
our world right now like i've done
something wrong
wait how dare you
bring attention to me doing something
wrong and
i mean i guess across the board i mean i
see that with people in my personal life
i mean everything it's it's everywhere
so i don't get that you're right you
know he's in this situation because of
himself we're all happy he's back we all
you you fought very hard and said a lot
of things about him deserving another
chance and that he had paid his penalty
with all the suspension and all that but
so you you've really you stuck up for
him that way but yes oh he got screwed
he got screwed the way the nfl handled
him last year he served a 14-game unpaid
suspension last year because the nfl
wouldn't tell any interested teams
whether or not he'd be put on the
commissioner exempt list end result he's
suspended without pay for 14 games and
then they slap him with another eight
games this year it was wrong even though
his behavior merits criticism i don't
believe that you should use the fact
that a guy has done unsavory things
allegedly or actually as justification
for depriving him of his rights and they
did in my opinion chris yeah no i i i
understand that
you reminded me of that yeah reminded me
that i was pissed off about well yeah i
just i well i was trying to remind
everybody else though even though you're
you know and we're both saying yeah
you're the one to blame antonio brown
you also did stick up for him that way
and hey we're we're glad he's back i'm
excited to see what he's got to see the
combination with him out there with all
that talon and tampa and brady and
everything and let's see what it's worth
but uh we'll certainly be watching
closely sunday night to see how he looks
i think one thing we all just need to
generally remember when people are
accused of doing things they shouldn't
have done they do still have rights and
they do deserve to be treated fairly and
properly by the legal system by their
employer and see what happens is when
there's somebody who does something that
makes them unlikable
we all become less sensitive to the fact
that they do have rights right but you
know what
one of these days
those rights
may need to be exercised by you
by someone you love by one of your
friends by someone you care about
whatever the case may be so those rights
are there to protect all of us and we
always need to be sensitive to that and
i do think the nfl handled him
improperly
last year and this year because he could
have been playing you know this pr
obsession the nfl has now as it relates
to off-field misconduct where we don't
even want a guy who's been accused of
something that makes us uncomfortable
onto the field even though his rights
haven't been resolved yet that's what
leads to situations like this here's a
little antonio brown talking about his
new housemate tom brady if you didn't
notice the tb12 here he is gushing about
his quarterback
tom is my boy uh
one of the greatest leaders to be around
you know he's encouraging
always inspiring he bring out the best
of the people around him uh he wanted
the best for everyone around him
i mean he's the greatest quarterback all
time nothing i've done in the past
matter he always getting better
day in and day out
and uh i just learned a lot from him you
know uh
how he trains how he take care of
himself professionally
his discipline his work ethic his
approach
uh
he's been a great guy in my corner and
uh
one of my close one of my close friends
see i think here's the reality antonio
brown is a guy who in many respects is
completely and totally incorrigible will
listen to no one will respond to no one
responded to mike tomlin until he didn't
and the one guy i think who has reached
him who has gotten him in line and
gotten him to behave is tom brady chris
i think it's obvious and i think that's
why brady wants him in tampa he knows
what antonio brown can do on the
football field and i think also
you know when you're the one guy that a
guy no one will listen to actually
listens to i think that creates an
unnatural affinity and a friendship
there and i think tom brady feels
responsible for antonio brown and i
applaud that aspect of it
that there is this real friendship and
that there's respect that is keeping in
line a guy who otherwise was all over
the place doing all sorts of things he
shouldn't have done
so
look maybe this was not going to work
anywhere in the nfl maybe there's only
one place it was going to work wherever
tom brady happened to be and it was
never going to work in new england when
tom brady was there after what happened
last year so now it works in tampa and i
think i'm rooting for antonio brown i
want this i think this is fascinating i
love a good redemption story and if
brady can keep him in line i think he's
still got plenty of good football left
in the tank especially with all the
weapons that they're gonna have around
him yeah i would think so too i would
you know he's he's a psycho antonio
brown as far as staying in shape staying
football ready i mean you heard bruce
arians last week talk about like oh he's
ready to go day one there's no doubt
about it i mean that's that's the famous
stories you always hear about antonio
brown you know and i've witnessed it in
person too in practice i mean it's it's
full steam ahead from the second he gets
out there he attacks it so i think
there's like a common place that brady
and antonio brown have right off the bat
they love the work they love to put in
the work for their craft so they can be
their best on sundays and then you know
hey there's not a whole lot of people in
the world
who
can put themselves in antonio brown's
shoes
and brady does have a great way about
him he's genuinely a nice person he's
got great charisma you know he's easy to
talk to he really is
and i think for a guy like antonio brown
who yes you know rich and famous and man
everybody's trying to get at me and
wants a piece of me good and bad and
everything like that
i think when you see another guy that's
in that situation and yet you go man it
just seems like it's all harmony in his
life and he's got it figured out and
none of these things
in the outside world affect him i think
that's probably where the relationship
really grew to where he could respect
tom brady and be like wait he's cool and
a great guy and he's like me in a lot of
ways but you know for somehow some way
he's focused his life in and got it all
straight and i think that's probably
where he looks at brady and isn't like
amazed and he's kind of his role model
and that's why he's willing to listen to
him and take to him and kind of be his
you know
robin to to brady's batman at this point
and and i think there's an important
point in all of that too
when you consider the background of a
lot of nfl players and the fact that all
of a sudden they become very rich and
very famous at a young age
it's a lot you never know who to trust
yes you never know who to trust because
all of a sudden you've got people coming
out of the woodwork who under the guise
of helping you out are trying to pick
your pocket and you get overwhelmed by
that
and in this setting it's obvious that
tom brady does not need to worry about
trying to take advantage of antonio
brown in any way shape or form tom brady
has already won in every way possible he
can genuinely be interested in helping
antonio brown but there still is a
selfish motivation there chris because
look if tom brady didn't see a high
level of potential performance in
antonio brown i don't think well yes tom
brady would be
spending the time and the effort and
whatever
marital equity remember when he was on
with howard stern back in april and he
talked about how his wife wrote him the
letter about balance and stuff you know
i don't know what the family thinks
about the new house guest
who's living with tom brady but you are
encroaching upon other aspects of your
life
to get the most out of this antonio
brown relationship and and and let's
let's let's be real about it even
even though
tom brady isn't trying to pick antonio
brown's pocket tom brady wants antonio
brown on the football field because
antonio brown is going to help tom brady
get to seven right and that's that's
that's that that's why this friendship
is there if this guy was just some
schlub some slappy some guy off the
street
tom brady's not giving him a room at
derek jeter's mansion no no he's not
you're right you know and and that's i
hear that a lot from the naysayers right
now oh i mean brady he wouldn't care
it's not naysayers
i know i know but you know it's it's
trying to put it all in a negative light
or a little bit like it's the truth i
know it's the truth it is the truth but
yet like you can't handle the truth i
can soldier hold on and let me explain
something for a second but i i think
i think the thing
you know where that gets a little bit
like lost in translation or whatever is
first off we don't know what he would do
for other people but second off okay
yes i mean
it it all conveniently works he's not
gonna just oh hey hey coach you know i
got some crappy receiver down the street
and uh i like him and i'm in this corner
and i'm trying to help him out you know
i'm gonna let him stay at the house you
think we can have a shot to make him on
the team it all worked the team needed
it you know he knows how good he is yes
he needs him personally and then also
he's friends with the guy and he wants
to help him out personally and that's
where it goes together i mean yes you're
right i you know johnny
uh x receiver who was on the practice
squad who has life problems yeah it's
that's not the same
situation so i know how it looks and
you're right it is the truth but there's
a lot of circumstances that play into
that
it doesn't make it not a good story but
we need to be realistic about it i don't
want to get caught up in some mythology
here that this is some altruistic
endeavor by tom brady he's getting
something out of it too potentially ring
number seven surpassing michael jordan
and then maybe walking off into the
sunset unless he develops a taste for
number eight
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports